yeah hello and welcome to this video
covering another game from the leeches
4444 24 25 45 competition I'm sorry for
that and yes this is the game I say
potato took me Otto we understand what
that mean what that means that that his
name is called I say potato and like its
reboot so let's have a look we have a
sloth the old main line of a slob the
modern main line probably is the three
line which is more optional nowadays
okay what was he 3 the nine network and
seeing a lot over the years 95 is the
alternative think it's usually it's
often called the Dutch variation III I'm
just current in wondering why is it
called the Dutch variation in the over
elocon match 95 was mostly played i
believe and then was played in the
netherlands so it would make sense to
call that the Dutch variation and okay
let's have a look what happened like
play tonight bd7 certainly possible am
Bishop before is the more conventional
move and if not one earlier than here
the ship before black usually tries to
ya put a bit more pressure on the center
it's interesting to note that while the
slab is considered to be a classical
opening this old main line sloth is not
so classical at all like it's giving up
the center was taking but what he gets
is a good structure and chances to
attack the wide center later visually 7
is a bit more passive in that regard
Queenie two ND flow of course like drops
to g4 and now white clay to move
hive immediately I don't like it to be
honest the thing is with the bishop
being on his heaven black is more
passive in this position it does not
have for example potential come to place
based on taking the night or queen 85 or
anything like that the bishop is just to
be passive them I understand that if
I've is a normal way of playing but
structural wise but I think why should
probably wait for a moment here and play
like he usually does in those positions
start with rookie one or maybe specially
for those kind of things I'm still
keeping some options open it's not
necessarily yet to play a five we note
that after five and this was played and
black is now completely flexible
regarding his structure compared to
other lines the bishop is also on is
heaven now instead of before which no to
say instead of before which is probably
also helping him more than anything the
bishop one before oftentimes doesn't do
that much if you don't claim you five
immediately and play something like this
for example removal t1 will be useful in
many cases for what insignia scenarios
where you play in 51 stairs where you
don't but black now will almost
certainly have to make a move what might
make a move that does not fit that well
into this scenario where lies advances
so wise having more space oftentimes
should keep the tension a little bit
more and keep let's say options open in
regards to what structure you play for I
think this helps black as now is
completely flexible with a set up and
let play the move Queen to be six now
this is of course not terrible however
I would strongly suggest to play not be
8 i'm really liking this move the night
is not doing anything on the seven at
all and the night will be very nicely
placed on physics sometimes it can go to
before but more importantly it
pressurizes the default on and on this
heavenly it's really passive i think
it's fairly clear that the night should
be there on c6 while it's not clear that
you have to put the Queen exactly on b6
sometimes you might want to play Queen a
five or something else the other thing
about Queen B sixes and why didn't play
that you can just push it away yes like
probably having to go back now and then
it really didn't help at all so I think
previous six is a bit inaccurate a five
could have been played now of course in
the game it happened a little bit later
here we note that like plate 98 after
all but that Queen B 6 action didn't
tell more that much yes Lucas snow here
but that wasn't extremely pressing and
in any case I think and the position is
fairly okay for black why doesn't really
have all that much on the king size and
on the Queen society also yeah it is
rather weakened we should be 29 36 and
Bishop each where I think I would have
played a 60 it like do this immediately
I think it's again it's roughly equal
this should be too and now I think like
should have taken the opportunity to
play the new asics this is fixing this
pawn on f5 and there are scenarios where
black is winning this pawn for example
something where Bishop be form is
creating the dark squared Bishop you
might have a scenario where night into
Queen attack upon and there is no minor
piece
to help the Queen with defending this I
think a six was a good opportunity for
black he played the immediate Bishop
before after which widened a 6 ok b6 i
think i would rather take or play this
letting the bleep on is weaker than the
apron is also before coming up and i
don't like to get into this position
here with the advanced pollen asics this
pawn can be a weakness and we will see
later in the game that this happens but
this is mostly because white made
mistakes well i played this one looks e1
e2 z1 and now a black probably should
take on d 2 is the simplest is a simple
isn't at least take him and go from this
position you can play an for example 9
a-5 in this situation or can play a
strengthening move the thing is not so
much that this is fantastic or anything
it isn't it's just okay but he went here
and this is ignoring the white idea why
had a threat but it was not yeah
realized so maybe it was the idea the
actual idea in the indie game by the
player because then you would have
played it yeah white now could have
taken on c6 that's a technical shot you
should not miss this is creating bad for
blacks giving white too strong minor
pieces so we're talking about this but
now 92 and all of a sudden this is on
this is just a piece down
get after Luke takes which it takes wide
again has two pieces for look after Luke
c2 is still a bit actor huh nine here
Queens the seven would be one there is
no meaningful playable this is covered
this discovered two discovered and the
only thing that wide needs here is to
coordinate his position just a little
bit better so something like here and
here would probably mean the end of the
game so that was a big opportunity and
white taking him he didn't do it he
played we should be five giving up on
this would create and now wide stops the
trade stuff yet this thing I don't know
it will lead to this situation and here
white is struggling black is quicker on
the sea from the best option now would
have been to tape on c6 and play the
night here what would be want something
like that and i am that p1 is actually
also interesting trying to close that
down my notes had night f1 the idea
being that you want to play the Queen
and 93 and then the 93 would cover the
important c2 and c4 squares those
infiltration squares now here I don't
know that runs the troops it to
immediately and then maybe still it can
go here and then 93 I mean more him I'm
sorry sorry I wasn't mostly I wanted to
do this but beach was hanging your made
you have to go here and then 93 yeah
that's better that's better I mean this
is not fun but you can look at the game
the game was worse in the game I mean
this is hanging with check so why has to
do some
in the game why playgroups III and the
dead position is really terrible now
like takes and now place Quincy eight
double or putting up this battery
against this is report and looking at
this I think this position is very bad
that looks bad why does pester there's
no counter play at all he tried them
roots in one probably not quite the best
choice and it neglect lasix maybe night
f1 immediately was better than this is
not condom back here I'm not sure maybe
why can hold but it's absolutely
uncomfortable this this Bishop here I'm
through not good Luke c128 was even
worse forever as now it's a basically a
dumb low-tech and a six it's tough to
cover that why tried but after Bishop at
five it did not help Queen to be five of
course not this now and there is a
teammate exactly so h6 first yeah and
black is winning hear him it's nothing
more nothing less he will win one of the
pawns and the resulting position is
pretty terrible so and this is how the
a6 pawn or lost any pushed on the
queenside route c6 bishop here was a bit
better even threatening to take this is
not healthy but it doesn't make huge
difference the position is pretty awful
anyway
27 yeah black explain this a little bit
passively Quincy one is a lot stronger
24 going for this and you are told when
you have the extra pawn something like
him yeah okay can you win everything
here with checks okay still black retain
the winning position there is no doubt
yeah Quincy five was played by why this
makes it quite easy because you can take
and you are quick enough to pick it up
here the white player resigned yeah
there were one or two key moments in
this game I think wide release the
tension a bit early in the center giving
black the structure which in itself is
not so bad for my at all but it's a very
comfortable version there 98 and so on
like didn't really make much all of this
and I think the position was roughly
equal after this however white was
indeed yeah it was probably equal but he
who takes his six was the big
opportunity that white should have taken
at the matter of those pieces look see
six takes and takes to the night this
kind of backward moves are often the
ones they overlook here it's not much
fun but you should avoid route 33 the
backwards only on the top open file
together with this vporn is probably
impossible to defend in the long run
okay hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this game thanks for watching